this is the number one emotional gap
there's one side that is in love
and the other side doesn't even know
that like they know that there's a lot
of beloved fans
but they don't know who they are they
don't know what they're loved at
how could they satisfy their need of
attention
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford let's talk
fans meet assaf nevo the ceo and
co-founder of pico
get personal a data-driven fan marketing
platform
helping sports organizations across the
globe identify their digital fans
nevo and his team of founders are
revolutionizing fan marketing and in
turn the fan experience
through pico's ai and data capture
technology with more than 50 plus
international teams
pico is leading the paradigm shift on
fan marketing and data management
creating opportunities for personalized
fan experiences that entice greater
levels of connection from fans
to franchises assaf novo thank you for
joining me this morning how are you
i'm good michael how are you i am
fantastic i'm excited to talk about
you know the integration of technology
of sports
teams and fan bases and creating this
you know this engaged crowd
and obviously sports and fans is one of
the you know the oldest phenomena
in in the world i can already i can
think all the way back to the colosseum
right with the gladiators and the fans
on the sides
cheering and screaming and and you know
while i may not be a die-hard fan myself
in some sports i see you know around me
all all these amazing people that are
just
you know crazy about their team and
crazy about what they're doing and so i
really want to get into this mindset of
of why does that happen and how do you
use pico
and and leverage people to help teams
create that engagement
but before all that stuff i'd love to go
all the way back to your nightlife days
and
your your integration of tech into
nightlife tell me about that and then
we'll transition into your current
startup
yeah well it looks like it's going to be
super super interesting as we've been
you'll be noted like few points of the
most important points of my life
currently so
maybe we need like few hours to come
along
i don't have anything today we can go on
yeah so starting
you know night life is a is a market or
or a business that has like a real
um sometimes cliche about who's running
it and when i started my journey
at the nightlife i came like you see
like i'm a super geek i don't i don't
look like maybe like the ordinary
nightlife owner as you would expect to
expect me to look
or feel but when we started this
business it was 20
2007 i was like 23 years old
and what really what really burned
inside me was the
the need of opening a place that's going
to be clean clean in terms of
you know working with all the required
regulations and with insurance and
paying the employees as needed
and like to prove first to myself but
also to the world that
this this cliche about these type of
businesses doesn't have to really
really be like you can actually run a
successful nightlife business and
still you know remain like a regular
human being without doing things that
you're not supposed to not that i'm
saying everybody does right don't quote
me on this but but there
there's a there's a way people look at
nightlife businesses
i remember few uh people i wanted to
rent apartments from who didn't want to
give me like let me rent it just because
i had a bar
and a nightlife business so there is a
how do you say stigma on people who run
run nightlife businesses
we really try to break it and show that
this is a legit
successful big economic uh you know
type of business but and what was the
integration of tech into it so what was
different about you know
rather than just saying i'm gonna open
up a bar like you know we've seen
and they're doing homage to weather but
how how do you actually go about and you
know leveraging
these different expertises that you
bring with you
to try and make it more successful so i
think it's a good question i think
the one thing important to know about me
and also about the team
and my founders and my uh the people who
work with us
we are really tech savvy so from my very
first company was when i was 15
i actually started to build website i'm
just at the side note i'm 37 these days
so we're looking like 20 years more than
20 years ago
internet just started to be in israel um
i wasn't such a good
student at school and i really like tech
so
i kind of like taught myself how to
program it was pearl back then
all command line you know super ugly no
ideas no anything and
and i started to build websites for
companies i actually built the first
like website with a with um with a
database for
manpower like a big manpower company
their name was actually name power the
brand name was manpower
um so this is where it started and and
when we started the uh
berkey which is which is the nightlife
business um
[Music]
we really wanted to focus on the
business side and then
as this started and grow and and started
to be more stable
all of our tech savvy expertise come in
place and we started to think of okay
how can we make things that are cooler
how can we make it efficient uh the
first thing we have done
is that we said okay one of the biggest
problems in the nightlife industry i
don't know if you ever sat in a bar and
and the bartender like poured a beer and
then his keg
ran out and you got this explosion right
and you get messy
everybody gets messy and also from from
a technical standpoint not
many people know that depending on the
length
of your um pipe there's a lot of
beer going to waste because this
explosion this is when all the gas gets
into the pipeline it's meant that for a
while you need to know for beer that you
just need to throw out because it's
going to be super guessing
as the bomb used to have don't don't
take me on this i'm not sure i think we
had 11 beers
at the highest peak we have like every
every beer line had like at least
three meters of uh you know kegs running
through
so you have eleven one and multiply by
three meters for each
you're talking about tons of beer going
to waste so we started to investigate
how we can actually
uh stop this and we found that there is
this tool i'm not even sure what's his
name
but it's like this small cup that you
can install on the keg
which like when when it explodes when
the cake ends it kind of like capsulates
the gas
and and stop it from from stealing and
instead of having all the gas getting
into the pipeline you just put it like a
side
and then you can you can just unheal it
on the side instead of getting it into
the keg
once we've done that and we installed we
hire we ordered this from the united
states from like us
super experty brewery who have all these
equipment
we installed it and then and then we
immediately saw like a huge drop in the
amount of beer we had to
to spill down and then we said okay
that's that's not tech that's cool but
that's not deck and then we said okay
what if we will put flow meters on those
on those uh
um whatever the name of this product
they forgot it
uh it has like an official brand name um
what if we put flow meters and then we
will connect these flow meters into a
simple program that will kind of like
ping every once in a while the flumeter
and see
see how we're doing we can actually
measure how many beer of every keg we're
actually using
and if we know what is the exact
milliliter that we have poured we can
then recalculate
all of our business mechanism on the
back end better
so we started to do that and from that
we grew to to say okay that's cool
now that we know exactly how much we
report why don't we give the power to
the customers why don't we let them pour
the beer
and then pay for exactly what they pour
instead of keeping it
tight to you know like a pine or a third
liter or half a liter
glasses we'll just give them a generic
glass something around
like this like a regular 333
milliliter glass and they will pour
whatever they want because you don't
always want to pour the whole glass
sometimes you want to take like small
zips because you want to keep it fresh
um and we build like this
self-serving bar which you can sit on
you'll get
a real tap like a bartender you get a
glass and you just pour as much as you
want and you have a screen
review that helps you yeah and you can
actually pull whatever you want
you give us your credit card at the
beginning of the night there's also a
business mechanism behind it saying that
you're probably you're probably going to
drink more which is you know you don't
want everybody
anybody to be drunk or drive or
something but at the end you want to
sell more that's
that's the one way of sailing and when
this pro when this uh um
project started to grow we went over to
coca-cola and said hey we have this cool
thing we've built
why don't you fund that and if it's
gonna work here at aubar which was a big
place here in haifa israel
uh you can take it naturally because we
are not gonna
we want to stay in our business so that
was our first you know bar
nightlife related uh technology thing
by the way it failed it didn't work at
all
but but it was a great experience in uh
in terms of working with coca-cola
but what i love is that we focus you
know uh eight minutes talking about you
know the journey and the exciting parts
of it and the innovative nature of it
and
and why that was such an exciting time
and a you know a fruitful time
and then obviously you know the end at
the end is is interesting but it's not
the important piece of the whole puzzle
it's
you know the the the philosopher's
throughout that segment of the journey
and the stuff
you take that same excitement and you
bring it now to people and you're and
you're
now instead of integrating technology
with nice life you're integrating
technology with
something that is a very low tech on
purpose which is
sports right sports of right human the
human to human interaction
is is important it's live you know
rather than what
we're getting used to today which is all
pre-recorded so it's a it's a whole
different industry
what is sort of your insight into the
sports industry in the fan industry
then you say okay i think there's a room
here for something like
so it's a good question first of all
it's not sports only so pico is maybe
in sports we are a leading leading
company uh we are also operating in
other
uh in other industries like the esports
uh we also have some traction coming
from
uh uh you know big consumer brands part
of our partnership we have with sap
but let's focus on sports for a second
because it's a one of our biggest
verticals
uh pico is currently working with 60
professional sports teams from around
the globe
mostly professional from the nhl nfl you
know bundesliga
premier league the bigger the bigger
part of the sports industry
um i think
that the one thing we we really quickly
notice is that there is a big gap
and the gap is is more of an emotional
one in one side you have a fan
who's like you said fanatics he's on the
colosseum he's doing everything
to to to you know to get in front of the
brand he loves the team he loves
and then he does a lot or she does a lot
in order to get their attention
they follow them they look at what they
do they engage
they watch you spend a lot of their
energy and time on on being part taking
part of this brand
um on the other side there's the sport
team well like you said it's an old
school type of
brand sometimes um some of them are more
innovative than the others but at the
end of the day they are focused on the
sports
that's what they do best all the rest is
kind of like a
wrap to the sports which doesn't really
know the fan
right this is the number one emotional
gap there is one
side that is in love and the other side
doesn't even know that like they know
that there's a lot of in love
fans but they don't know who they are
they don't know what they're loved at
how could they satisfy their need of
attention
so the the problem with the bigger clubs
is that they're so big and so noisy
that it sometimes looks like everything
is okay and that this relationship
doesn't have a gap
in if you're diving deeper you see that
at the end of the day
if you would ask most sports teams the
bigger one of the world
do you know which fan like which player
in your team which you you know that's
good that could help you assume
what's the passion why why does he
follow the team what's what's keep him
up
you know from uh on doing this they
would say we don't
so you're saying okay that doesn't make
sense i had a relatively small
comparative sport team a relatively
small business and i know everybody
i have data about everybody anyone who
bought something anybody who sits we had
this uh
subscription royalty program like we did
a lot in order to gain data about the
people who come to the bar because
that's
that's the way we're marketing them and
and i think in bars life in nightlife
business nobody is in love with the bar
you go to one bar today you'll go to
another tomorrow there's almost zero
emotional
connection here there's such a deep
emotional connection people could
you know fan a team like a team from the
day they're born to the day they're
dying and
at the end of the day the team doesn't
know that you exist
and that's a gift that's so strange um
you know it's not so strange when you
really think of that from um
it's not coming from you know bad
purposes it's coming from the way people
consume these days
and and when you're consuming content or
things that you love today
you're not always aware of how many uh
processes are happening in the middle
between
you know a to z and what happened in
sports and it happens in other
industries
in industries as well that sports are so
focused on the engagement on creating
the content
and creating the things that's going to
make you come in and engage with them
and they didn't spend enough time
because mostly because they don't have
the expertise because they are sports
teams they know how to play sports
um they didn't spend time on
understanding who you are
like they're not always aware of the of
the ability to create like a fan journey
that we need for knowing better who you
are and then you know convert
you better in sport conversion is not
necessarily
sell you something it could be just
let's send you the right content you
want to see instead of seeing generic on
you know that makes a lot of sense yeah
how do you actually go about and now
helping these
you know these teams integrate and
understand get insights into their fan
base so how do you actually go about
you know taking all that like no black
hole and making it as transparent as
possible for them so that they can
you know actually take actionable
insights from that
right so first of all you mentioned
transparency and one of the important
pieces when you're running a data
company especially in these markets
which are very very sensitive
to you know to the way they look to the
outside and they want to create a good
experience that's
actually in course everything is about
the experience transparency is important
and when we are gathering data and
helping teams understand their fan
better
the fans also know that we are doing
that so it's super transparent and when
a fan share data with us
he does or she does that in a way that
they know that this goes
to building their relationship with the
team it doesn't go to any other
evil purposes and that's uh that's
important
um the way we operate is that we we know
teams are very good at engagement
but we know they don't know who they're
engaging with so we built
a suite of tools it's now pretty wide
with lots of sub products and such but
it knows how to take engagement on any
digital channel whether it's the website
the app social networks
whatever identify the fans who are
engaging and then
progressively at data about them so we
are creating like one source of truth
for every fan
and then we'll keep building data about
each of them so with the first
interaction with you we might get your
email and then at the second interaction
we will ask you who is your favorite
player
and then what's your merchandise
preferences and so on the databases
so let's say ideally we want to have
around 30 different data points
on each fan and then we use these data
points in order
to create this profile which then the
data
we then is then connected to build
better marketing campaigns so
more of a technical side how it works we
have
we are analyzing what's engaged we're
looking at the team digital channels
we're looking
what's mostly engaged by fans we take
this content
and we're attaching experiences and
activations to this content like
fun things fans like to play so let's
say uh game day content is also very
it's all always very engaging you can
have like today's the game day
you can have a prediction game of who's
going to score the first goal tonight or
who's going to win
this experience is built by pico and and
it will always be engaging because this
is the the game
is when fans are at the highest speed
in this two-sided marketplace what is
this sort of the responsibility then on
the consumer so as a fan of the company
what is my interaction
with pico in that regard first of all
you don't know pico exists because it's
white label
and it's embedded inside the channels of
the team so you would see a facebook
post or a twitter
tweet or a section at the website or a
notification in the app or a banner at
the app saying like
um who do you think is to score tonight
click here to vote or click here to play
you click it
you start a game this game asks you who
do you think you're going to score it's
very graphic it's very fun
you pick it ends but during this game we
will ask you hey michael
um we are giving away
uh a jersey you know of your perfect
player of one of the voters today
how do you want us to announce that
what's your email address what's your
phone number
how do you prefer us to communicate with
you so now you we have your email and
when we ask you for an email we would
say okay michael would you like us
would you allow us to use this email to
further communicate with you and you can
say yes you can say no
if you say yes then you're getting into
the you know subscription plan and all
that
you get newsletters and such if no
that's fine we will not bug you
we know that you're a fan that don't
want like ongoing communication you just
want to be occasional whenever it works
for you
and then at the second game you play we
already know your email address now we
will ask you great michael
uh if you're gonna get this jersey we
just offer which of the player would you
like to sign it
right and then you pick it we know who
your favorite player now and so on so we
have this process
every time we put you in front of
different content it's not always games
you know this was a very rough example
it's not always that raw
but but the idea that we're engaging
with fans in way that allows them to
share information that we have an
ongoing conversation with them
through this conversation or through
this communication we ask them
questions so this is the one the one
hand of pico this
this process brings in a lot of data
because fans
are very happy to share they are very
um very enthusiastic about the fact that
the team actually cares about them and
want to learn more about them
so they're sharing a lot this builds a
big big database
now the second step is to take this data
segment it normalize it in a way that we
can have
um we can build recommendations to teams
what to do
the most obvious use case would be you
know taking as an example the los
angeles lakers
on christmas time we are saying hey
lakers you have 30
000 fans who express an interest in new
jersey and also their favorite player is
lebron
so let's send out a marketing campaign
to them at any channel
at the channel that they engage with you
so facebook fans are going to get
a facebook promotion twitter going to
get on twitter and so on
and the call to action would be hey
michael here is the jersey of lebron you
wanted click here to get a 20
discount so there's much higher
conversion that way instead of just
sending you to the store
with a discount right exactly this is
not just relevant for
sports this is relevant for any brand
that wants to make meaningful connection
we see this
across the board from high tech to low
tech it's it has like you know sports i
think is just a great
vertical because you already have that
you know proof of concept that fans want
to be engaged with the brand they want
they want to be you know die hard fans
even when there's a lot of friction and
i think what's remarkable here is that
what you're saying is that there's
actually a lot of friction right now for
for you for people to be really fans
right
you know it's not the teams have a hard
time uh facilitating that
and giving those opportunities and
they're still doing it so they've
already sort of done the product market
for you you just go in and facilitate
that behavior and say okay can we
extrapolate this behavior
to also other brands around the world
exactly so i think if you look at sports
and the difference between sports and
other markets
it's not even sports it's entertainment
compared to other markets because music
has the same problem like if you
if you like justin bieber you're
following him you're watching his videos
you're listening to his music but he
doesn't know you exist
so we're here you're already there and
the difference between sports and
entertainment compared to other
industries
is that other industries will pay a lot
to get the traffic
sports gets for free and and the fact
that we don't need to bringing the
traffic the traffic is already there
there's already already a bucket of tons
of fans or engaging
that's that's where it comes and started
to be really interesting so we always
you know cherry picking the industries
we're operating it
which is this is the main formula we we
want to have high engagement rates
we are not the type of companies that
will bring in the traffic like we can
but that's not the technology the
technology is about operating in spaces
where there is a lot of engagement
i can give you an example of another
market we are looking at now with the
sap partnership
we look at consumer package goods
companies like nestle
they don't have they're not selling to
the end consumer they're selling to the
retailers
these retailers you know like walmart
they're selling the end serial
to the to the customer like if you know
if i like frosties
in the morning the the brand
i'm not even sure nestle is is the a
multimeter frosty
is nestled but let's assume it is um if
i'm consuming nestle
if i'm consuming frost test prosthesis
nestor has
has no data about me right but they are
spending a lot on creating
a digital engagement they have influence
levels
the blogs they have this that wraps up
their marketing system
and at the end of the day they don't
have data about the end consumer so they
are now starting to use our technologies
in order to create engagements that
really drive data less for
uh marketing directly to the consumer
because they don't have a selling point
more for understanding who they are what
their unique preferences and then
building their own whole strategy around
it
because currently they're buying market
research from you know deloitte mckinsey
and all these uh big brands
uh which at the end of the day is not
necessarily based on one-to-one
interactions with fans
right no that means that makes a lot of
sense you know like we said before we
can
and talk about this for four hours right
it's not me at some point i think what
you're doing with pico is it's
phenomenal and i think that this whole
idea of
facilitating engagement and and
understanding there is a marketplace
here that both sides want it and there
is this big
yeah and just like in the nightlife
industry that you found i think that
it's a very small behavior and i want to
thank you for being so generous with
your time 20 minutes go by
so so fast and but really spending this
time with me and
i have the most important question
before we end which is three words that
you would use to describe yourself
wow three i can give you one
uh i already have two okay so that's
right so first and foremost i think on
the very core i'm a builder
so i like to build stuff that that's the
first one um the second one i think
not sure i was always like that but i
learned to be optimistic i think
optimism is one of the most important uh
you know key factors you have to be when
you go to entrepreneurship
being able to see good stuff on when
everything crashes
that's super important um i think the
third one
award um i think resilience
like i'm resilient i'm i'm not affected
that much with
you know with failures and such i love
it
thank you very much very much best of
luck with pico and i look forward to
sharing this with all thank you
thanks michael
[Music]